the maker movement is getting it's an
emerging movement that has kind of
captures the and the dreams and
aspirations of a pretty large portion of
the United States I mean 56 57 percent
of the people will self-identify as as
makers but we're specifically targeting
the creative class which is a subset
within that group about 40 million of
them in the United States this comes out
of dr. richard florida's work over a
decade ago the book called the rise of
the creative class they actually control
something like 70% of all the disposable
income in the u.s. four hundred and
seventy billion dollars they tend to
aggregate in the major cities not to
surprisingly like in New York LA San
Francisco Austin texture is a membership
base to do-it-yourself
a fabrication studio membership based
means for a hundred and twenty five
dollars a month you get access to all
the tools that you need to make just
about anything
do-it-yourself means you do it we don't
do it for you so even though we have
machine tools woodworking plastic
electronics textiles 3d printers great
be huge water jet that will cut through
five inches thick of anything on the
planet laser cutters it's you do it so
it's it's DIY so the reason the reason I
got involved I was at a software party
an event and I overheard Jim Newton the
founder say over over my shoulder it's
kind of like Kinkos for geeks
and I actually ran the Computer Services
section of Kinkos across the United
States so I if you think about Kinkos
the geeky part of Kinkos is the computer
area at least I would argue that and so
I cornered them and told them like I am
Kinkos for geeks you know what what are
you doing and so he described tech shop
20,000 square feet all of these tools
and so I went and visited it and what
happened for me is I talked to three
different entrepreneurial groups
back-to-back and each one of them told
me that they had saved ninety-eight
percent or so it's like 97 98 99 percent
of their development costs by working
out of that tech shop and so what they
had they gone out and had bids one was
like three hundred thousand dollars to
get one prod
another one was 200 and other was like
250,000 and they each said that they had
started their company one was like
$20,000 in another was like 10,000 last
one was like $2,500 in and they you know
they pointed us like you know you know
what are you doing say well this is a I
was an infrared pet warming device like
a great big huge plastic with with the
wires in it and the idea is that the dog
or the cat comes out of surgery it needs
to be warmed the current technology is
wet blankets in the microwave that's not
really a technology in my mind but
that's what they were using to keep the
dogs or the cat's warm sometimes they
would get burned sometimes somebody
would get distracted and then the you
know the wicking would actually make the
the dog or the cat get cold rather than
trying to warm them up again and so is a
simple idea was we'll just use infrared
you know you set one dial based on the
size of the the animal another dial bait
based on the thickness of the coat and
another timer so it just goes off after
about 10 or 15 minutes simple really
good idea and Annie said Polly yeah I
was a great idea but my original bid was
for $250,000 and then he looks at me
says you know mark I I'm a roadie for
stain I don't have 250,000 dollars my
wife's not gonna let me take a alone out
on a house for an infrared pet warming
device and so you know I've been sitting
on it for the last three years
discovered TechShop for 2,500 bucks I've
got my first production prototype
he's now sold millions of dollars worth
of these things and that's the magic if
you can take something that used to cost
you know small house and you can make it
so that anybody in the middle class can
afford it
2,500 bucks I would argue if you can
afford a Starbucks addiction you can
afford a shop membership and you can
innovate that is really revolutionary
and so I stood at the end of that after
its meeting these three guys and it's
like this Bruce Sterling that says you
know the future is already here it's
just not evenly distributed I was
standing in the physical instantiation
of the future was it was clear as day
not only are people doing interesting
projects like the world's fastest
electric motorcycle did 218 miles an
hour on the Bonneville Salt Flats one
Pikes Peak the
last year actually destroyed the Ducati
Superbike by like 20 seconds the world's
most efficient data cooling center the
world's cheapest drip irrigation system
in all of these things we've had some
that have come out that are actually
changing the world and this is
definitely my my favorite it's called
the embrace infant warmer and it's a
simple technology there's a polymer
pouch that goes in the back here and
what you do is you heat the pouch up
slip it in here and it keeps the child
warm so the where it started was a woman
named Jane Chen was in the Stanford
d.school
and as part of the d.school you do a
couple of things you either you know
work for a corporation on a problem
they've got or you find a problem that
you want to work on and so she and her
friends hit the World Health
Organization's website was kind of
rooting around for a while and then they
discovered this particular problem that
if a child was born 2 weeks too early
their hypothalamus isn't fully developed
and they can't regulate their body
temperature now their lungs are fine
right if they're if you're if it's if
it's a month early then they've got
other issues but if it's just 2 weeks
it's just a matter of managing that
temperature and it turns out hundreds of
thousands of babies die every year
because they can't get to an incubator
within the one hour that they need to
before serious medical problems and I
said it so the idea here was this
polymer would keep them keep the pouch
warm and it would extend that hour - and
actually by the by the end of the school
year they had it to another hour so you
know had two hours to get the child to
to an incubator but then they graduated
and I came to came to tech shop in in
Menlo Park and a lot of these stories
come out of Menlo because that was our
we've been open there the longest then
magic happened and the the locations
that we have turned out to be the most
kind of creative aggregators of amazing
people in any city and so noggin on
murti was the chemical engineer who was
sitting at a table working on working on
some something and a chemical engineer
came over and asked him some pointed
questions like hey noggin on have you
ever scaled the polymer before like no
he just got
you know he just graduated you know how
much do you know about these particular
polymers you're working on it's like you
know very little just what I've learned
I learned in college so turned out this
guy had like 30 years of polymer
experience and worked with noggin on to
upgrade the core technology in this and
they upgrade it from one hour to four
hours so this is a like a three-fold
increase but then because you put it in
a geography it's actually a nine-fold
improvement in the reach so their core
technology was donated to them by
members in the community and that's one
of the unique things about being able to
have a large-scale makerspace in the
city is it advocates those folks so this
blanket has already saved 87,000 lives
Jane Chen was named a World Economic
Forum fellow and has had an amazing run
and so that's why you know I like to say
it's not only I do these spaces enable
you to pursue your dreams but they can
also enable you to change the world in
very positive ways